of some breaking news now relatively
good news new figures from the office
for national statistics shows that the
number of deaths registered in England
and Wales over one week has fallen below
the five-year average that is for the
first time since the week ending March
the 13th while at Conway our economics
editor has been tracking these
statistics throughout the outbreak Edie
it is good news Adam and it's been a
long time since we've been able to say
that we've been tracking these data
showing you excess deaths which is
basically the most comprehensive measure
of how many people have died across
England and Wales and indeed the rest of
the UK compared with the seasonal
average and as you know it's been very
high over the course of the last few
months but the good news is for the
first time since the onset of this
pandemic there are not excess deaths
across the UK and I say the UK because
we can look across all of the UK I've
taken number trend in the Worlds which
we've just got this morning but I've
also added on figures for Scotland and
Northern Ireland as well they have a
slightly positive territory excess
deaths there's still more people dying
than the historical average in Scotland
Northern Ireland it's very small at the
moment and if you take all of the UK we
are now down below this line you will
remember probably this line this line
shows you the average number of people
who have died in a given month weeks of
the year and you can see it tends to
peak around the start of the year and
then drops down through through the year
as it goes on let's have a look at
what's happened so far this year you can
see 2020 a very big increase there a
spike in xs/s so you can see the number
of people dying of all causes has been
above the average significantly above
the average but look at those lines on
the far right hand side those lines have
finally converged now that is good news
it is the first time that has happened
since the beginning of this pandemic as
I say that's for the UK as a whole so
have taken inland and Wales and also had
its Scotland and Northern Ireland when
you take all of that in total there were
20 few fewer deaths than the seasonal
average in that latest week of the years
the 19th of June is the way that we're
talking about
if you look just at this period as a
whole because now we are for the time
being at least and hopefully for good at
the end of this wave of excess deaths we
can start to kind of toss up the total
death toll from this period and you can
see 65,000 total excess deaths and of
those 54,000 of those are put down to
covet 19 so finally some good news when
it comes to mortality in the UK we are
at an end of that period of excess
deaths across the UK and they have you
had a chance to look at the different
trends in the different nations of the
UK I certainly saw one chart yesterday
suggesting the infection rate is
dropping much more quickly in Scotland
than in England for example well
actually you know excess deaths which is
probably the most kind of comprehensive
measure when you when you kind of look
but obviously it is lagging as you know
excess deaths are actually in positive
territory in Scotland
and slightly positive territory in
Northern Ireland so in this last week
England which hitherto had certainly had
the highest mortality of any of the home
nations had actually fallen quite
sharply so excess deaths had dropped
much more sharply in England than in
Scotland and Northern Ireland
so that is reassuring in the England was
the real hotspot for a period it'll take
some time there Adam before we know what
the final death toll is because it may
well be that this line there's black
line that we've been focusing on an
awful lot may well be below that average
line for some time and so we won't
really know how it washes out what the
ultimate death toll is and that's why I
think you know it's tempting to try to
compare the UK with other countries
around the world and indeed though on
almost every measure the UK is one of
the worst in the world but getting a
definitive sense of how the story here
compares with other countries will take
some time because we are still in the
relatively early stages but as I say the
good news is this terrible peak of
excess deaths that we've been suffering
from in this country for a long period
has now finally finished hopefully good
for good we don't know we'll have to see
what the later the next few
week spring but that really is a
watershed moment in this pandemic